الان بدا نزول
الاشخاص على متن او رعايه بعثته هموم
المتحده ونشاهد ايضا هذه السيده والتي
ترافقها احدى المجندات السعوديات من الحرس
من حرس الحدود وكذلك جود من حرس الحدود
يرافقونها في عمليه نزولهم وهي من الدفعه
الاولى طبعا الفئات المخصصه للاحتياجات
الطبيه هم يقومون به الان النزول والمتوجه
مباشره الى مركبه الاسعاف كما نشاهد التي
خصصتها الصحه وهي هيئه الهلال الاحمر
السعودي وكذلك السلطات السعوديه وتامين
صحه وسلامه رعايه بعثه الامم المتحده تحمل
هذه الفرقاطه قرابه ال400 شخص من جنسيات
مختلفه هناك السلك الدبلوماسي لعدد من
الدول سواء الدول من اوروبا وكذلك امريكا
وهم ايضا سوف يستقبلون بعض من بعثه الامم
المتحده يتواجدون الان هنا على الرصيف
ميناء جده الاسلامي هنا ايضا وصول او نزول
ايضا المزيد من
الامم المتحده ورعايه الامم المتحده الذين
وصلوا للتو الان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات